well it is over the blockade by
protesters that had prevented the
ambassador bridge from being open for
the last seven days police broke it up
today early sunday morning they started
that effort saturday but it stalled
protesters had come out last night
vehicles were still in the area
they had a problem they decided this
morning to take a different tactic a
different tone yesterday's tactic on
saturday was very much asking protesters
to leave pleading with them that that
was the best course of action today it
was very different the rcmp were in full
force today the rcmp tactical assault
vehicle was brought up to the front of
the line they told people that they had
to leave and then police officers
converged from the front and from the
rear and pushed
the protesters together they also
knocked on the windows of the pickup
trucks that were parked in that area
they told the drivers to get out and
then each of the two drivers would
refuse to leave was arrested and when
they got to the corner where we are
there were some other vehicles some
larger trucks and those trucks decided
that they would leave of their own
accord there were no arrests made here
so after
seven days
trying to resolve this this situation
has been resolved by way of some arrests
by way of police action and now we wait
for the bridge to reopen sean o'shea
global news in windsor ontario